[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture au
sommaire de ce mercredi 28 septembre on
ne présente plus ces textes blanc sur
fond noir aux graphismes si
caractéristique l'artiste ben expose
jusqu'au 27 novembre à la maison elsa
triolet aragon le temps d'un après-midi
la laiterie de la reine à rambouillet a
fait un saut dans le temps les curieux
ont voyagé à l'époque de marie
antoinette et trois artistes soutenus
par le prisme d'elancourt ont été primés
lors du off du festival d'avignon nous
les avons rencontrés ben peut être
provocateur théoricien ou encore
analystes et jusqu'au 27 novembre
l'artiste interroge les visiteurs à la
maison elsa triolet aragon
l'artiste né en suisse et qui vit
aujourd'hui à nice était présent lors du
vernissage de son exposition who will
friedrich et nicolas kirillovitch sont
allés le rencontrer
[Musique]
des réflexions des interrogations depuis
les années 60 ben pose sur ses toiles
ses humeurs ses états d'âme ici à la
maison triolet aragon il part à la
recherche de la vérité où est passée la
vérité c'est le nom donné à cette
exposition présentée jusqu'au 27
novembre moi j'ai aimé l'idée d'exposer
des déchets à elsa triolet aragon parce
que
je me demande je sais pas une
connotation intellectuelle qui me
servait à quelque chose ou pas mais ça
m'a plu et puis j'ai vu les dépliants il
ya eu mes amis monory et compagnie qui
ont exposé ici donc je me suis dit c'est
un beau lieu mais savait pas qu'il y
aurait tellement demandé je ne savais
pas que c'était si important que ça une
recherche sur la vérité mais aussi et
toujours cette introspection guise de
fil conducteur l'égoïsme la recherche du
succès ben assume et revendique ses
contradictions c'est un peu hamlet un
peu un peu quelque chose de moi c'est
que un à dix candidats en compte que il
est toujours à la recherche de la boîte
est à la recherche de lui même et elle
est chaude donc un moment donné
ils s'aiment pas beaucoup mais il peut
pas faire autrement donc elle avec il ya
du moment où on déprime de l'idée du
mois qui ne pensent comme moi
plasticien ben est aussi un performeur
il aime interpellé son public et
n'hésite pas improvisé lors du
vernissage une conférence interactive
sur son travail il ya des passages dans
lesquels les gens bien pleine bulle de
champagne hawks et ben oui c'est beau
magnifique symbole cela et en fin de
compte c'est je peux faire
une exposition dans lequel on est beau
contre j'aime j'attaque soutien des
boucs qui est du doute
égocentrique mais qui aime être bousculé
dans ses certitudes ben est un artiste
provocateur et pour saisir les
subtilités de son oeuvre le musée
maillol à paris lui consacre en marge de
cette exposition une rétrospective
complète
si vous n'avez pas pu le découvrir lors
des journées du patrimoine
il y à une séance de rattrapage le
théâtre montansier à versailles propose
de découvrir ses coulisses dans le cadre
du festival d'île de france qui se tient
jusqu'au 9 octobre dans toute la région
le théâtre présente cette saison 45
représentations dont une quinzaine sont
des créations le théâtre montansier est
l'un des plus anciens de france a été
inaugurée en 1777 par louis saez et
marie-antoinette geneviève dichamp sa
directrice nous en donne le programme
on va replacer le théâtre dans son
histoire expliqué quel a été le rôle de
marguerite brunet qui a été son
initiatrice à qui elle a acheté ce
terrain pour pouvoir le construire
comment elle a fait valider les plans
dans les petits salons de
marie-antoinette quel était son goût
pour le théâtre est pourquoi l quel
était son histoire personnelle et puis
ensuite on expliquera aussi les
différentes restaurations et et tout
cela en se promenant dans le théâtre et
en montrant aussi théâtre sous
différents aspects
depuis près de 20 ans les amis de langue
de coignières propose pas mal de
concerts pour cette saison 2016 2017 il
y a cinq rendez vous autour de langue
bien sûr au sein même de l'église de la
commune
certains disent de l'orgue qui vais le
roi des instruments depuis maintenant 19
ans celui de coignières est au centre
des dimanches musicaux les concerts
reprennent le 2 octobre à 17 heures avec
le trio à coup l'un flûte traversière
saxophone et mais org et c'est un trio
qui vient du sud de la france
deslandes et qui propose de faire un
petit parcours musical à travers les
compositeurs du la fin du 19e siècle
arrivé à l'église saint germain
d'auxerre en
1993 grâce à du mécénat l'instrument
fait aujourd'hui partie du patrimoine
connaît rien
toute la musique du xviiie siècle au 20e
même 21e siècle
sera présente mais nous avons associé
sur certains conservent des instruments
qui seront pas du tout courant et qui
permettent de d'écouter autre chose que
des instruments à cordes avec avec
l'orgueil orgue de cristal ou encore
hommage aux femmes compositeur quatre
autres rendez vous sont proposés tout au
long de la saison l'instrument roi
attend son public
[Musique]
retour dans le passé pour le domaine de
rambouillet ce dimanche 25 septembre la
laiterie de la reine est revenu le temps
d'une après-midi à l'époque de marie
antoinette pour découvrir les plaisirs à
la cour les images sont signées nicolas
kirillovitch
sa femme marie antoinette elle n'aime
guère rambouillet elle qualifie de
gothic crapaudière le roi décide alors
d'en grand secret de faire étudier dans
son domaine de rambouillet puis deux
laiteries
rambouillet fin du xviiie siècle
marie-antoinette vient découvrir le
présent de son époux le roi louis saez
un cadeau pour lui donner envie de venir
à rambouillet la souveraine préférant
rester à versailles nous ne sommes pas
dans une reconstitution historique parce
qu'une de nos difficultés notamment
c'est que louis saez ayant acheté sur
ses propres deniers c'est en fait une
propriétaire royal mais privé sur lequel
il ya très peu de traces d' archives
lorsque louis saez fait aménager cette
laiterie de la reine
il ménage la surprise de la reine en
faisant construire une palissade de
verdure que nous n'avons pas
reconstituée mais nous avons déplacé
cette palissade de verdure au niveau de
la grille de manière à ce que
l'ouverture permettent de découvrir
cette façade de temps plein
dimanche dernier un après-midi à la cour
était organisée dans ses costumes du
xviiie dégustation de macarons ou encore
intermèdes musicaux
l'après midi était à l'image de l'époque
de quoi attirer un public de passionnés
la période me fascine oui tout à fait
les costumes encore plus et le plaisir
de se retrouver tous ensemble et de
partager ces moments inoubliables
nous venons de loin de toulouse et donc
on aime on aime participer à ce type
d'événement je ne connaissais pas le
milieu donc c'était l'occasion de
découvrir la literie la reine et puis
pour le plaisir de venir avec des amis
et de les revoir et se balader en beaux
costumes une soixantaine de personnes a
décidé de faire le voyage avant de
revenir au 21ème siècle
elles sont deux sur scène et une 3e
complètent le collectif les filles de
simone elles sont les créatrices de la
pièce c'est un peu compliqué d'être à
l'origine du monde soutenue par le
prisme d'elancourt créé au théâtre la
loge à paris la pièce a obtenu un prix
lors du dernier off du festival
d'avignon nous sommes allés à leur ordre
e rencontre
[Applaudissements]
chloé olivères es sétif en gentilleau
sur scène est clair frétel à la mise en
scène raconte la vie d'une mère lors du
festival d'avignon 2016 elle remporte le
coup de coeur du club de la presse on
était hyper contente parce que on s'y
attendait pas du tout au fond plus
c'était un jury majoritairement masculin
donc on était d'autant plus
ravis que innu sélectionne les fumeuses
c'est fini
[Musique]
de la découverte de la grossesse aux
premiers instants avec bébé en passant
par l'annoncent à l'employeur
toutes les étapes sont décryptés avec
humour et surtout de la franchise pour
casser l'image sacralisé de la maternité
c'est pas une pièce comique parce que
c'est pas ça qu'on cherchait mais on a
voulu aborder des sujets qui n'étaient
pas forcément simple qui parfois été cru
mais c'est vrai que comme on part de
notre vécu et que on a aussi pas envie
de se prendre trop au sérieux forcément
l'autodérision il n'y arrivait très vite
on a surtout travaillé sur le fait
d'être très proche de soi donc en fait
sur une forme de sincérité ce sont deux
comédiennes qui sont deux femmes et qui
sont deux mamans donc en fait c'est pas
un thème de travail de personnages
extérieurs finalement c'est un travail
de chercher d'amener au plateau quelque
chose de d'être vraiment à vif et au
présent au plateau joué plus de 20 fois
cet été la pièce est née d'un besoin de
s'exprimer et s'inspire de simone de
beauvoir et elisabeth badinter
interprété pour la première fois en
février 2015 le spectacle était soutenue
et coproduit par le prisme à elancourt
elles correspondent à beaucoup de
paramètres et de critères ce qui est en
jeu c'est de soutenir la création
émergente donc de jeunes artistes qui
ont envie de dire quelque chose la façon
de le dire c'est essentiellement le jeu
dramatique l'écriture et pas forcément
des hommes de décors ou des tonnes
d'effets spéciaux on est vraiment au
coeur
je travaillais atral et de l'écriture il
faut prendre garde que les décisions et
sentiments avenue et de la jeune mère ne
correspond pas toujours à ses désirs
profonds la pièce continue sur sa lancée
elle se joue au théâtre du rond point
jusqu'au 2 octobre
des places sont à gagner avec tv fil 78
pour aller voir avishai cohen trio
prisme accompagné d'un bain d'un
pianiste d'un batteur le contrebassiste
de jazz avishai cohen renoue avec ses
débuts direction la page facebook de la
chaîne pour connaître le règlement
du côté du cinéma c'est celui du cratère
à sainte anne où les humains qui
accueille vendredi 30 septembre les
mutins de prize une rencontre cima
cinématographe rick pour découvrir
réalisateur et acteur la soirée est
organisée par des associations qui sont
sortir avec les mains nues templay et
l'école de la cité le public sera amené
à voter pour son court métrage préféré
parmi les huit présentés écouter julien
dénervaud c'est l'un des organisateurs
du projet
décider vraiment de faire un projet qui
regroupe effet trois d'antibes est rare
et de créer un un échange de faire un
vibrant votre autour du cinéma et la
vidéo est aussi accessible au public
sourd puisque tous les films sous titrés
en avec un sous titrage adapté et pour
l'occasion une base on a eu des
interprètes par donc j'appelle le jury
de l'autre et qu'il a défendues
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et qu'il
conduira la soirée en langue d'études
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine on se rend dans
un cinéma saint quentinois cette semaine
c'est luc bocandé cette marque qui nous
présente son coup de coeur donc aussi 17
nous sommes gourmand donc cette semaine
on vous proposera deux coups de coeur je
vais commencer par victoria le second
long métrage de justin triais près la
bataille de solférino rien à voir avec
la bataille de solferino qu'on n'avait
pas trop aimé ici aussi des 16 c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire là on se trouve face à
une comédie dramatique tout à fait
réussie avec virginie efira qui est
vraiment extraordinaire à l'apogée si je
puis dire de de son talent c'est très
sympa ça se laisse regarder c'est
intelligent de l'histoire d'une avocate
je vous en dis pas plus qui a une vie
privée on va dire chaotique et qui va
être amené à défendre un de ses amis qui
est jouée par melvil poupaud
qui a des problèmes de couple etc voilà
donc ces savoureux vincent lacoste qui
joue aussi un des premiers rôles est
extraordinaire donc n'hésitez pas à
venir voir ce film c'est vraiment une
réussite si vous voulez passer un bon
moment et notre deuxième coup de coeur
évidemment c'est juste la fin du monde
le sixième long métrage du grand de
l'excellent et du pourtant très jeune 27
ans de xavier dolan c'est juste
magnifique alors on aime ou on déteste
ça je peux comprendre que des gens qui
n'aiment pas du tout c'est l'histoire
d'un huis clos au repas de famille avec
la secret familial je ne vous en dit pas
plus il faut bien voir le film c'est
insupportable parce qu'on est vraiment
dans une dispute familiale et on est si
je puis dire le cinquième invité on est
on est à table avec eux on vit le truc à
l'intérieur de l'intérieur avec ses
tripes vincent cassel léa seydoux
nathalie baye enfin ils sont tous
vraiment formidable
gaspard ulliel et sait rester là mais je
vais en oublier dont venez voir ce
sixième long métrage de xavier dolan on
conseille vraiment donc victoria est
juste la fin du monde
avant de se quitter un rendez vous
samedi c'est la 5e édition de la nuit de
la création à versailles un parcours
relie une douzaine de sites de la ville
autour d'un thème versailles ville
lumière et ça commence à 20h le 7-8
culture est maintenant terminée je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je vous
dis à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]